i'm just going to run through your
rights in that property okay
thousands of desperate private renters
are turning here for help
the housing charity shelter say they're
receiving a record number of calls to
their helpline from renters struggling
to pay their bills or facing eviction
we're hearing from worried frightened
callers every day about what rising
living costs mean to them they've got
nothing left people are
right at the edge of what they can deal
with when they call us
and you do get people who were ticking
by and suddenly there's this change
in affordability and they have to choose
is it heat is it food
is it rent five times a week
someone will cry down the phone to me
sometimes you can give them some good
news and they're like
such a relief but then
a lot of the time
there isn't any good news
but the latest figures from shelter
suggests the cost of living isn't the
only threat to tenants
evictions are on the rise too making a
bad situation much worse for many
renters
one of the callers to the helpline is
carl from north london i've just
received um an eviction notice from um
my letting agent and i've been in a
state of panic to be honest with you i'm
just i'm desperate
really yeah so this is the kind of thing
we do in workshops carl is a musician
work dried up during the pandemic and to
make matters worse his landlord has
served him with an eviction notice it's
called a section 21 no fault eviction it
means carl's done nothing wrong the
landlord just wants him out
without any warning without any prior
notice uh uh notice of eviction came
through the door
and i was literally it
i'd i was in a state of shock after
having paid over in mice and in my case
uh somewhere in the region of 70 000
pounds over the course of this tenancy
i can be kicked out unceremoniously with
no consultation
three years ago the government promised
to scrap no fault evictions but it
hasn't happened yet instead a
spokesperson told us they'd be banned as
soon as possible
a private renter in england is handed a
section 21 no fault eviction notice by
their landlord every seven minutes
according to shelter this gives tenants
just two months to leave their home and
the landlord doesn't need to give any
reason for evicting them
since the government said it would
abolish them nearly 230 000 private
renters have been served with a formal
no fault eviction notice
private renters really need to be
free of this incredibly unfair law
there's no need to be able to evict
somebody for no reason
we're pretty much unique in this country
um that that can happen to families to
individuals um in private renting it's
causing um it's decimating lives and we
see that as shelter every day
but landlords say they should have the
right to take possession of their
property if they want to
sometimes they want to sell it sometimes
they want to renovate the property from
top to bottom um or they want to move
back in themselves so if you get rid of
section 21 orders and the landlord wants
the property back but the tenant isn't
in arrears has done nothing wrong
what options does the landlord have well
they don't really because the the
section 21 gives them that facility um
for no reason to ask that tenant to
leave legally
so they're stuck they're stuck
carl is fighting to stay in his home
while at the same time is desperate to
get back into the rhythm of his work
the sheer cost of living means the
future is uncertain nick martin sky news